hi my name's Michelle I run blab muffin
beauty science I have a PhD in chemistry
I'm a skincare nerd and I'm an acid
addict not that type of acid I'm talking
about skincare acids today I'm going to
be talking about some of the best acid
ingredients that you can find in
skincare in chemistry an acid is a
substance that donates H+ also called a
proton when I say the word acid you're
probably thinking of bubbling test tubes
chemical burns melting skin but the
right acid ingredients used in the right
amounts can be really beneficial for
your skin in fact your skin is naturally
acidic thanks to the acids in your sweat
and the fatty acids released from sebum
the oil that your skin naturally
produces the thin film of acidic group
on your skin is called the acid mantle
it's really important for keeping the
right balance of bacteria and other
microorganisms on your skin so that the
friendly microbes are happy and the
harmful ones can't get too much traction
the pH of your skin should be somewhere
between 4 and 6 let's get started on my
favorite acids alpha hydroxy acids or a
a chaise ingredients that have a hydroxy
or a H group on the carbon next to an
asset or COOH group because of this
positioning Ajay's have a special
property they can help your skin
exfoliate the top 10 to 20 layers of
cells in your skin are dead around one
new layer of cells is produced every day
so one layer needs to come off or
desquamation
to keep your skin in equilibrium if it
doesn't come off properly you end up
with dull flaky rough skin lots of
things can go wrong with desquamation
for example dehydrated skin that lacks
water doesn't come off properly your
skin tone over also slows down as you
get older alpha hydroxy acids help
loosen skin cells said that they come
off more easily it's not a hundred
percent established exactly how a shave
do this but so far we think that they
bind to calcium ions which makes the
dead skin cells break up the dead skin
cells come off more easily and is
smaller less noticeable pieces this
means you end up with smooth clear
glowing skin Ajay's also change other
aspects of how skin works it increases
skin plumping collagen and increases the
proportion of younger cells in your skin
Ajay's also reduce fine lines prevent
acne fade dark spots increase skin
thickness and even out skin tone and
texture they also act as humectant
moisturizers that help your skin hold
onto water there are a whole bunch of
different AAAS that can help your skin
out and they all have different
properties my favorite so far are
glycolic acid lactic acid and mandelic
acid glycolic acid is the smallest and
most popular of the alpha hydroxy acids
it was my first ahe and I was so
impressed when I tried it I tried a
sample of Paula's Choice 8% a H a gel
overnight and the next morning my skin
was smooth plump and glowing since
glycolic acid is the smallest a Shea it
gets into the skin more easily and more
deeply than other aged shaves this means
that it will usually be more effective
but it can also have more side effects
like colic acid is the most irritating
of the alpha hydroxy acids it also has
the most research to back it up it's the
active ingredient in a whole bunch of
cult skincare products including p50
lotion alpha h liquid gold and pixie
glow tonic it's also commonly used in
peels for treating acne and pigmentation
sometimes along with microdermabrasion
or micro needling if you're starting on
a glycolic acid product I would
recommend a leave on product that's got
lower than 10% concentration and a pH
under 4 or 5 you should also use
sunscreen when you're using glycolic
acid since it makes your skin more prone
to sun damage even when it's not on your
skin you can use it in the morning or at
night if you want to find out more about
pH and
you can check out my older video on pH
and PK lactic acid is the best research
alpha hydroxy acid after glycolic acid
and it's my current favorite and I use
all of these products lactic acid is
notable for being gentler more hydrating
and more effective at treating sun
damaged skin it also increases the
ceramides in your skin ceramides are one
of the three oily lipids in your skin
that's important in keeping your skin
waterproof so your skin will stay
hydrated
like with glycolic acid I would
recommend starting with a leave on
product with less than 10% lactic acid
and a pH of 4 or 5 if you haven't tried
any alpha hydroxy acids before lactic
acid is also in yogurt but it's usually
at less than 1% so yogurt masks won't be
anywhere near as effective as a leave on
product mandelic acid is another alpha
hydroxy acid and I've only recently
started using it in this fall beloved
one product it's only really been
studied in peels but it works a lot like
glycolic and lactic acids because it's
quite a bit larger than glycolic and
lactic acids mandelic acid doesn't
penetrate as deeply so it's even less
irritating and has a more even effect in
peels in peels it's commonly recommended
for ethnic skin that's more prone to
rebound hyperpigmentation which is when
an irritating treatment makes your skin
more pigmented salicylic acid is a
really popular anti acne treatment
it comes from Willow Park and is
structurally related to aspirin so it's
got anti-inflammatory properties it's
also commonly referred to as a beta
hydroxy acid much like alpha hydroxy
acids if then exfoliate your skin and
keep your pores clear reducing acne you
can find salicylic acid in lots of
products like serums spot treatments and
cleanses it's usually at a concentration
of Nohr point 5 to 2 percent although in
spot treatments it's usually higher it's
also used in high concentration in peels
for treating acne acne scars
pigmentation
sun damage and age spots you can also
find it in water and corn removers
there's some evidence that ph isn't all
that important for salicylic acid
products so if you want less irritation
you can try a higher pH treatment
azelaic acid is one of the key
ingredients in lots of prescription only
acne creams it's usually a 15 to 20
percent
there aren't many side effects to
azelaic acid unless your skin is very
sensitive in which case it can give you
a little bit of steam redness and
peeling you can also use as a lake acid
to fade pigmentation like post acne
marks the brown marks that are left on
your skin after you've had a pimple also
known as post inflammatory
hyperpigmentation or PIH in combination
with retinoids azelaic acid can work
almost as well as hydroquinone retinoic
acid is better known as tretinoin it's
the active ingredient in creams liked
retin-a and Renova
it is the gold standard of anti acne and
anti-aging treatments it's a form of
vitamin A and it's backed up by tons and
tons of studies treasurer Nolen works by
reducing clogged pores so you end up
with less acne it also increases the
amount of collagen in your skin which
means it prevents wrinkles it's also
handy for fading dark spots threatenin
is super awesome but it's also really
irritating so when you use that a lot of
people end up with red flaky itchy skin
it also causes purging you can find
treasure naans weaker cousin retinol in
lots of skin care products like this one
it's less effective but it's also a lot
less irritating ascorbic acid is the
most common water-soluble form of
vitamin C it's also the best research
version vitamin C has a whole bunch of
awesome benefits for your skin like
treating pigmentation and increase in
collagen ascorbic acid is an antioxidant
that protects the skin from damaging
free radicals that are made by UV
radiation and environmental pollution
these are one of the main causes of skin
aging the biggest problem with ascorbic
acid is that it breaks down in water
really quickly if it's combined with
other antioxidants like vitamin E and
for really acid it breaks down way more
slowly but this also tends to make the
product really expensive I usually make
my own DIY vitamin C serum so I can make
sure it's fresh and save money you can
also find more stable forms of vitamin C
and skin care like magnesium as Korbel
phosphate and tetra I soap amytal
ascorbic acid but there's a lot less
research on these linoleic acid is a
fatty acid that we usually find in
skincare oils the difference between
linoleic acid and other assets is when
we're talking about linoleic acid in
oils it's actually being reacted to lose
the acid group and it forms a
triglyceride
so it won't donate H+ linoleic acid by
itself can lighten pigmentation but in
oils most of the linoleic acid won't be
free to lighten your pigmentation like
and normally would but it isn't entirely
useless and skincare oils I personally
love oils that are rich in linoleic acid
because they tend to feel a lot lighter
which is really nice when you have oily
skin like me that's a quick overview of
my favorite skincare acids do you use
acids did I forget to talk about your
favorite one let me know in the comments
if you liked this video please subscribe
to my channel check out my blog and
follow me on Instagram I also have a
free exfoliation guide on my blog which
you might be interested in if you want
to find out more about acids see you
next time for more beauty science
[Music]